[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, everybody. Welcome
to the Data Science Hangout.
Let's get things
kicked off here.
Hope everybody's
having a great week.
I'm Rachel Dempsey,
if I hadn't haven't had
a chance to meet you yet,
and I lead our pro
community at Posit.
Data Science Hangout is our
open space to chat about data
science leadership and
questions you're facing,
just getting to hear what's
going on in data across
different industries
all over the world.
But we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you are in the
future somewhere watching this on YouTube,
you can add it to your calendar
and the details will be in the
YouTube description below.
Brian, I think that's
actually how you found--
first found out about the
Data Science Hangouts.
But together we're all
dedicated to making this a
welcoming environment
for everyone.
We love to hear from everybody
no matter your level of
experience or area of work.
You can join in the
conversation a few different
ways and jump in
and ask questions.
You can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
And to get to that,
it's in the Zoom bar below
where you click on reactions.
And then, secondly, you could
put questions in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put a
little star next to it if you
want me to read it, maybe
you're in a coffee shop or something.
And then we also have a
Slido link where you can ask
questions anonymously too.
And I'd like to add in that
it is totally OK to just listen in
too, if you want. You don't
have to jump in the conversation.
But I am so excited to
have Brian joining us here today. And
before introducing
Brian, I forgot, Libby,
that I was going to have you
do a little 30-second pitch to
share something with
everybody here too.
So let me do that first
and then I'll jump over to
introducing Brian.
- Awesome Thank you so much.
This is a pitch on behalf
of Andis and I. If you've
been here-- there's Andis.
If you've been here
over the past few weeks,
you probably know Andis.
Andis and I are going
to be doing a reread
book club of ISLR.
We're going to do the
second edition because we've gone
through the first edition and
second edition came out, I
think, like August of last
year or something. And
it has fantastic resources
because everything is really,
really made available
by the authors online.
There's YouTube
lectures, there's slides,
there's all kinds of stuff.
So who is this for? If
you would like to join us,
we're probably going
to do it on Discord.
It's probably going to be
one chapter a month. And
it would be best for people
who are rereading, like we are.
A lot of people went
through ISLR in their past.
They're already pretty familiar
with all of these statistical
concepts and they would like to
dive into the second edition and
experience ISLRs
take on some of the new
material, like deep learning,
that's been added. So if
you are interested in that,
please private DM
Andis or I your email address,
just so that when we are ready
to do our thing together,
we can include you too.
Or find me on LinkedIn and
send me your email address.
That way also works.
Thank you, Rachel.
- Yeah, absolutely. And ISLR,
that's Introduction
to Statistical Learning--
- Introduction to Statistical Learning
in R, yes. Thank you.
Sorry-- all the acronyms.
- No, no. worries. Awesome.
That sounds great. Yeah,
feel free to put that
into the chat, of course,
to let people know who
are joining in later too.
But with that, Brian, thank you
so much for joining us today.
So Brian is our--
Brian Fannin is our featured
leader for the day and he's
currently a research actuary
at the Casualty Actuarial
society. And speaking of books,
Brian is also author of the
book R for
Actuaries
and Data
Scientists, with
applications to insurance.
So really excited to ask
you about that today too, Brian.
But to get us started here,
it'd be great to have
you introduce yourself,
and maybe share a little
bit about your role now,
and thing you like to
do outside of work too OK.
- So I'm an actuary and
have been doing that for--
we're almost at the point
where I can say 30 years.
I rounding up slightly
to get to 30 years, but.
I've been doing
that for a while
one of the first questions that
I get when I tell people that
I'm an actuary is what
exactly is an actuary?
I'll keep it very, very
simple for folks, though,
I'm happy to go into detail
if folks are interested.
An actuary is
an applied statistician particularly
focused on financial risk.
The
easier way to think
of that perhaps is
we work a lot in insurance.
We figure out what people
need to pay for transferring the
risk of financial loss to
damage to their car, to their
home, or to what have you--
any number of things. So that's
what an actuary does.
I've been with the
Casualty Actuarial Society for about
five years-- more than five
years. And we are very engaged
in professional education,
credentialing actuaries but
also actuarial research.
So that's where I nerded
up with trying to develop
new concepts to improve
the way that actuaries
can carry out their work.
I also do a lot of
speaking. As I mentioned I,
was just in Boston recently at
a conference, so I do dabble
somewhat in
professional education.
Outside of work, it
will be the same set of
nonprofessional hobbies that I
think everyone does that are
fascinating and
enriching to me.
I spend time with my wife and
my kids. I cook. I watch movies.
I can't think of anything
that would really distinguish me all
that much outside of work. I
like to travel, but we all do.
It's a really dreadful
dating profile,
but I'm happy to talk
about movies or travel [INAUDIBLE].
- Well, thank you so much
for joining us, Brian.
And I just shared the link
to the book in the chat,
if anybody wants
to check it out.
But, Brian,
something I thought might
be interesting to kick-off the
conversation with is--
I know you mentioned that a
majority of actuaries are still doing
the lion's share of their
work in spreadsheets, specifically Excel.
But I was just wondering how
you've seen that start to
change or how you think that
might be changing in the future?
- So it is changing,
albeit slowly.
And I can say that my
experience professionally as an
actuary for, oh, the first 20
years that I was doing this was
largely spreadsheet-based. That's
very, very common.
There's a very
easy on ramp for people
to work with Excel,
which I think helps explain
some of its ubiquity.
And I'll say Excel,
that's usually what I
mean-- the spreadsheet more generally.
But typically it's
going to be Excel.
Two years ago, the CAS
issued a technology survey
about what tools actuaries were
using because we're curious to
see how quickly it's moving.
What we found was 98%
of respondents-- and we
got about 1,000-some-odd
respondents, so a pretty
decent sample size--
said the used-- 98%,
I think, use Excel on
pretty much a daily basis,
whereas R or Python,
the numbers were
on a daily basis certainly
comfortably less than one out
of three. I would be one of
the ones who uses R every day.
We redid the survey last year
and the numbers moved a little
bit. That survey
will launch again
this summer and curious to see
if that slow and steady pace
is continuing. But,
anecdotally, I can say that
when I'm at conferences and
talking about some of the work,
I do talk to folks about what
tools they are using. I hear more
of a-- Python is moving
a little bit quicker,
largely because of R
had some penetration.
But I do get the sense that
there is a subtle shift.
A lot of it is going
to be demographic.
Within the actuarial community,
I'll be one of
the older R users.
They tend to be a little
bit younger than I am,
so that shift is partially
a generational change.
- And with that, have
you had experience in
helping bring people on board?
I'm curious what's been most
helpful for people just getting started.
-
I'm not sure what has or
hasn't been helpful for other people.
I can tell you my
approach has been to
zealously evangelize
using scripting tools.
I'll say R specifically.
It's the one that I came to
first and the one that I love
the most, but
Python is good too.
I have less to say about
the things like Julia or JavaScript--
JavaScript might not
be a great example,
but Julia would be a good
one. They're not bad,
I'm just not as
familiar with them.
And I think they don't
have quite the network effect.
But
evangelizing scripting tools is one
of the things that I do.
That's one of the reasons why
I wrote the book so that there
would be an entry
point for folks to
get familiar with the language.
Later today, I'll be
constructing a virtual workshop
for actuaries using R. And I
also assist with the Python instruction.
I hope that's helpful.
I can tell you what has
been helpful for me is just
recognizing the
benefit that I get from
using technologies
like R, like Python.
It has made me
a better statistician.
I suddenly found that when I was
able to script a lot of these models,
I understood the statistics a lot
better than I thought I did
when I was trying to
translate pen and paper into
a spreadsheet.
- Thank you.
So I get to ask all the
questions in the beginning as
we wait for them to
come in from everybody,
but something I find
really interesting is learning about
people's professional journeys,
and what takes you to
different companies,
and gets you to where you are.
And I know you've worked
across many different insurance
companies, like Munich Re
or Swiss Reinsurance. You were
chief actuary as well.
And I'd love to hear
about that journey and maybe
also what that transition has
been like going into this--
the Casualty Actuarial
Society, more of a
professional society
rather than a
large organization.
- Well,
I did say that I love to travel
and the ways that I tried to put that
into
action was I was
working in Chicago--
this would have been about
20 years ago now-- and
one of the professional
realities of white collar work
that some of us have
experienced, unfortunately,
is company where I was working
was sold to someone else
and so I thought, well,
I'd like to work
somewhere outside of
the United States.
So I have this opportunity
where I find myself
open to other
positions and
was able to move to Germany,
not because of I had said
that's going to be the place,
I phones a headhunter and
said, I'd like to
move somewhere on Earth where
English is not the
native language.
Within this particular field that
means-- if you want to be
a non-native-- or rather
English is not the native
language, that will be either
Switzerland, or Germany,
maybe France, maybe a
few other countries.
But that was where I
wound up. It was terrific
learning German, got
to travel quite a bit,
and got to see a very
different perspective.
I know that I'm--
I'm pretty sure that I'm
the only actuary on this call--
although if you're
not, please say hello.
So for people that are
not familiar with the field,
the perspective and the mode of
practice is different all over the world.
Actuaries in London are
different than actuaries in New
York, are different
than actuaries in Asia,
are different than actuaries
in Switzerland. So getting that
perspective was
really eye-opening.
Also,
fed into my interest
in R because the--
a lot of the folks that
I've worked with in Europe,
their statistical skills
were loads better than mine.
I think they're able to think
in equations and be able to do
things in ways that I struggle to
keep up with. So that fed into
my chafing
against the constraints
of the spreadsheet and
I'm going to say
my own intellect.
I'll go ahead and just out myself
with that. Like I say, I know
more mathematical statistics than
the average person on the
street, but I don't know as
much as the typical actuary in,
say, Switzerland. So
that was one of the
draws to getting me to R.
I hope that that's
interesting as a journey.
- No, that--
I love that-- that
you just said,
I want to go try
living somewhere else,
and learn another language,
and you made it happen.
I see a few questions coming
in the chat. And, Danielle,
I know this was also a
question to the group too,
but I was wondering if you want
to jump in and ask that here.
PARTICIPANT 1: Sure. Yeah.
My
company's finally looking into a
proper database to help store data
and I-- that is not my
area of expertise at all, I thought
someone here might have some advice.
When I look into different
kinds of databases,
seems like R and RStudio is
pretty set up to work with
SQL, like relational databases.
But I don't know what tools are
out there for if we wanted to
go with a NoSQL database.
If anyone has advice, I
would love to hear it.
- I don't want to
preempt anyone else responding to
your question about NoSQL--
the experience with working
with relational databases has
been pretty smooth.
I have, just for fun,
dabbled in MongoDB and Neo4j.
There are libraries out there.
At scale,
there may be some pain points.
But I can say that in
terms of prototyping
and just getting started, there
are packages that support, certainly, Neo4j
and MongoDB.
PARTICIPANT 1:
Great, thank you.
- Any other thoughts
of people with
experience with that?
I see there's a
follow-up question.
Which NoSQL database are using? Is it MongoDB?
PARTICIPANT 1: No.
No NoSQL databases yet. We
don't have anything selected. So
if anyone has suggested--
suggestions on which
one we should go with--
this is still a
very preliminary
exploration of which kind of
database we want to use. But,
Brian, you said MongoDB as well.
- Well, it would depend
on what your use case is.
I dabbled with NoSQL largely,
I say, just for some nerd fun.
Relational databases are a
very proven, reliable, scalable technology.
There are definitely
use cases for others.
And I think Mongo would be--
when I say Mongo, I mean JSON generally--
depending on what data
you're looking to analyze.
If it's highly
transactional, over the web,
then probably something like
Mongo may be attractive. But
your relationals
are really good.
- Sorry,
I was sorting through questions
and couldn't find the mute
button for a second.
But I see there was
an anonymous question asked on Slido,
which was what mathematical and
statistical methods do you use?
Are there packages
for this specifically?
-
And this being actuarial science
or are we still on
databases. I think we're going
back to actuarial sciences, yes.
- There are a few.
And I'll have to
reference some specific actuarial
techniques. There
is a technique
called loss reserving.
Effectively,
it's establishing the
amount of liability--
financial liability--
and I'll get back to the
boring stuff in a minute--
but financial liability
for insurance company.
Practically, statistically,
it is very similar to
longitudinal data analysis, not
quite the same, but
very, very similar.
That is one area where
there are at least two packages,
both of them are
called chain ladder.
One of them is an R and
then there was a port to Python.
Those are a couple.
There's a package called
Actuar, A-C-T-U-A-R,
which is I think of
French for actuary,
developed in France.
This is some
support for statistical distributions
beyond what you get
in the stats package.
Actuaries
often need to rely on
probability distributions
better-- that have
thick tails, all right?
So we've got highly skewed
distributions. This is a good
thing if you're a consumer.
It means that really
terrible things are rare--
really terrible
events are rare.
But as actuaries we need to be
able to come up with an estimate there.
So Actuar is another package.
I'm searching my memory.
That maybe about it,
the--
which begs the question
is that all that we need?
The answer there
is no. Actuaries
use pretty standard techniques,
like generalized linear models,
for a lot of the
work that we do.
-
I was just asking in the
chat if anybody was looking those up
and wants to share the links
to those packages in the chat,
that would be awesome too.
I see-- Adam, you had
a question in the chat.
And I'm actually just making
the connection now that Brian
had previously worked
at The Hartford as well.
Adam, do you to jump in
and introduce yourself.
- Yeah. Hi, I'm Adam.
I'm a director of data
science at The Hartford. So, yeah,
I just joined
two months ago. But it just
came up this morning, in fact,
that it's very common with the
rise of data science that we
often have lots of
resources, and cheat sheets,
and ways for folks to
understand what data science is
as it comes into
their business.
But we don't often see
it go the other way.
So,
yeah, I've been in the
insurance industry a few years,
but I know a lot of
new hires, especially in data science,
struggle with learning
those actuarial concepts,
and the jargon, and
what things mean.
And I'm looking for--
are there resources,
are there ways for us to
go out and find-- besides, of course,
your book-- are there resources
where we can go out and
understand these concepts and
use that to collaborate with
our product partners,
for example?
-
Everyone that I work with is
going to be really upset that I
don't have one of
those at the ready.
That feels like something
that someone has put together.
Oh, gosh,
I'm blanking on the
name of the organ--
the actuarial
foundation may have some
actuary and 101-type
of material.
But I--
oh, gosh, is there a way
for me to put something,
not in the chat, but but
after this, like a comment?
Yeah.
OK, cool. I--
Yeah, you can
Yeah, you can send it to me
and I can put it with the recording too.
OK. Yeah, I'll have to do
that. I'm sure that material exists.
I've not needed it
for a very long time.
Generally, if I'm
talking to folks,
even if they're
not actuaries, it's
largely more about
insurance terms.
Like if I say--
here's a good example,
like the abbreviation IBNR.
Actuaries know what that means.
So do a lot of people
in the insurance industry that actuaries
work with.
And
to end the expense, IBNR--
it stands for Incurred
But Not Reported.
That is an amount
of insurance claims
that the company must
estimate as being owed to
policyholders.
But it's
so standard on
insurance financial statements,
that even outside the
profession folks tend to know
it. If you're a data
scientist and, let's say,
last week you were working for, I don't know,
Best Buy or Home Depot
and today you're working at The
Hartford, you're not going
to know what that is.
PARTICIPANT 2: Exactly.
- You're not going
to know what that is.
So that kind of
material is out there,
but I'd have to look it up
to share it.
- OK, yeah.
- Yeah, we can definitely add
links after. But I see Darren
had shared one in the
chat, which I think
is related to this. Darren,
if you want to jump in.
- Yeah, so the
institutes which,
I guess, organizes designations
that actuaries tend to take--
so CPCU is a very common,
very big one-- but
they have a few other
very specific
designations that are
low effort, in terms of the
amount of work involved,
that I think are quite useful.
So one of them in the
chat is associate in insurance data analytics,
so that you could take--
it takes maybe like nine
months to complete fully,
but it's an official
designation that I think has
been useful for our team
also being an insurance industry in
terms of just getting up
to speed on basic knowledge terms
that can be very confusing
to someone starting off.
- Yeah, The Institutes
is a very good resource.
- Awesome. Yeah,
thank you so much.
I sit in these meetings
with our product partners,
and they're so smart,
and they have this whole
dictionary in their heads.
And so they're rattling
things off and I get lost,
so this is very
helpful. Thank you.
- Hang in there.
- Great, thank you.
OK,
I see a earlier question
you had asked, Bill.
I'm not sure if
you're able to unmute.
Do you want me to read it?
The question was--
Brian,
are your colleagues and peers
working on local laptops or
perhaps on-prem
larger system?
And the follow-up
question is would you--
your typical actuary need to
install and manage RStudio or
Anaconda on their own machine?
What does the setup
look like for them?
- Typically is going to
be-- well, I'll describe my setup,
which is probably typical
these days-- 2021-- '23-- 2023.
I have a laptop.
I work remotely.
So I've got a
laptop, which will
refresh to
some
corporation server.
We're-- and also--
sorry, Microsoft shop,
which means that we've got OneDrive
and so everything is cloud syncs.
And I think that's
fairly typical.
I have R installed. I'm
not using RStudio Server,
although, Rachel,
everybody ought to.
It's a really good
product. I have used it.
I know The Hartford does.
I did some consulting for
The Hartford and they had it.
And it was a
fantastic experience.
The installation of R
and RStudio is pretty
straightforward. It used
to be a lot more painful,
but I find that it's
pretty smooth these days.
So installing locally--
my use of professionally has
been largely on my own. The
collaboration has usually been between
me and someone at another company.
And their GitHub will be
the way that we're collaborating, ideally.
That's my favorite way to
collaborate or we'll get lazy
and use something like
SharePoint or just email,
forgive me. But those are
easy ways to collaborate.
Trying to think-- did
I get all of that?
Anaconda--
not actually a big fan
of Anaconda, it's really
opinionated. And I find
that whenever I install it,
I'll wind up with somehow
three or four different flavors of
Python on my device. I'm
probably doing something wrong,
it's probably my fault, but
I usually just install Python.
And as with R, it's usually
pretty straightforward.
If I were working with a
team of actuaries for an insurance
company-- that's not
my situation right now,
I'm one of only
a few actuaries--
but if I were working with
a team or managing a team,
I would do something
like RStudio Server.
Just make sure that--
I don't want to sound
like a shill for
[INAUDIBLE], although
I would love to,
I know that Microsoft and
others have similar cloud-based
solutions that would probably
work very, very well.
- Thank you. OK,
another anonymous question
was when you say that actuary
statistical analysis are
similar to longitudinal
analysis, does that include
survival analysis sometimes?
- Yes. Well, so there are--
globally,
kind of two different
flavors of actuary.
There's a life insurance actuary
and then there's every other actuary.
In the US, it's life and
health insurance. Outside of the US,
there is public health
insurance schemes and so
actuaries are just not--
there's not a demand for it.
But a life insurance actuary
would absolutely use a survival
analysis. I think a lot
of techniques that are in survival--
I'm not a life
insurance
actuary, so I'm talking out
of school a little bit.
But I think there are a
lot of techniques in survival analysis
that have their origin in
human mortality studies.
So def-- yeah,
survival analysis is
a thing. I wrote a paper
about using survival analysis in loss reserving,
so you could think of that
as a hybrid survival analysis and
longitudinal analysis.
- I didn't Google that
paper fast enough down there.
- There are better
sources out there.
- So, OK, maybe taking
a step back from some of the
insurance topics--
I know you said that you do
a lot of public speaking and
that's something that has come up as
a question before here in the hangout.
Do you have any tips for us who
are trying to get better at public speaking?
- I think
finding a friendly room is
not a bad place to start.
So, locally, here in Research
Triangle, North Carolina,
there are not very
many actuaries.
But I think folks realize that
this is a really good spot to
be if you're into data
science or statistics.
We've got the Research
Triangle Park,
we've got the universities,
and we've got [? SaaS ?] here.
So there is a very
active and super friendly community of
data scientists.
I'm
very much involved with
a meetup group of Research
Triangle analysts.
And
we have monthly meetings.
People can give talks there.
Really friendly room.
That's not a bad
place to start.
What else can I say?
Yeah, present to your family,
present to your friends.
That's another way to
find a friendly room.
And then, finally,
just keep doing it.
The first time that I
ever spoke at an actuarial conference,
I
was so nervous.
I thought that I was going
to have a heart attack. I
couldn't
believe just how
petrified I was.
But that was-- what was that? That
was 13, 14 years ago. It gets easier.
-
I love that tip of
just reaching out to different
meetups groups and speaking there too.
And I wanted to call out that
Abigail just put in the chat because-- well,
we were talking a little
bit earlier about this on LinkedIn.
But she was looking for
lightning talks for a DC
meetup. So if anybody
else organizes meetups and
have links you want
to share in the chat,
that would be great too.
- Yeah, pretty much any
major area is going to have--
I've not managed to get
any of the DC meetups.
But DC area is kind of
where home office is. So when I'm
going to the CAS
office, it's in DC.
And I keep trying to catch
up with the DC folks.
But if you're
in Boston, Chicago, Philadelphia,
there's going to be a data
nerd meetup in your town.
- I can vouch for Boston.
That's our group. [CHUCKLES]
I see, Bill, you had
another question in chat.
I'll read it here.
But Bill said,
"I'm always interested in
security and regulatory issues.
Do you anonymize or make
up fake data? If so, what
packages or methods
do you use?"
- Mm-hmm.
In the insurance space,
there is a need for
publicly available data sets for
research. As you can guess,
there are a lot of privacy
issues that would make people
uncomfortable, companies
certainly, and policyholders,
very uncomfortable
sharing that data.
There are a few, kind of,
toy data sets out there.
But we do simulate data for
research purposes from time to time.
When I'm researching--
well, two things.
One,
again, for that
reserve data, the
longitudinal-ish data,
there are several packages
that will do that.
There are about four or five.
If you're not an expert,
you've never heard of these things.
But that will simulate
these kinds of financial
transactions.
Beyond that,
fairly straightforward. The
ability to randomly
generate a number in R,
it's one of those
really bedrock things
that I really enjoyed
when I first started
using R. In Excel,
I can remember,
I wanted to simulate
something from a Poisson distribution.
At that time, probably still today,
there's no easy way to simulate
a Poisson, which is a
very, very common thing in actuarial
applications. So
you couldn't do it.
So I'm reading numerical
recipes and all these other
crazy things to--
I think maybe I
could've just inverted
the cumulative function,
but whatever. In R,
I don't even need to do
any of that. It's just
[INAUDIBLE], and I've
got 10,000 observations,
so things like that.
And you can stack them.
So if you've got, like,
a cascading process,
a sort of a
hierarchical simulation,
pretty straightforward
to do in R.
My favorite way
to tackle that is
I'm a very dataframe-centric
programmer.
So I've got a data frame
where I've got maybe 1,000 scenarios
that have different parameters,
and then just go row by row
using Per or
something like that.
Each row in a dataframe becomes
a new data frame that has a
simulating a scenario.
I can just
easily nest, and
un-nest, and summarize
all of that stuff. So
it's that LEGO-based approach to simulation.
- Great, thank you.
Maybe this is a question
for everybody on the call here,
too, if you want to share
links in the chat. But, Gaurav,
do you want to jump in here?
The question was are there
publicly available data
sets for casualty insurance?
- So I could've name
checked a few there.
There's the insurance
data package in R.
- OK.
BRIAN FANNIN: Yeah.
And there's another one that's not
on Cran because it's pretty massive.
I'll dig up a link to that.
- Yeah. You can send
to to me after too.
BRIAN FANNIN: It's all
set to go. Thank you.
- Yeah.
I'll try and make notes
of where to follow up.
Javier, I see you had
a question in the chat too.
You want to jump in here next?
JAVIER: Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, thanks, Brian. I'm
really enjoying your discussion here.
I work with a ton of actuaries.
I'm not an actuary myself.
But I work at a health
care insurance company. So
I'm in our data Science
Center of Excellence.
And a lot of our
stakeholders are actuary
or, you know,
finance-adjacent folks.
We've had a lot of
interest recently trying to get
what feels kind of like a
small army of Power BI devs to
tap into more, like,
Python and R-related
capabilities to
work in conjunction
with Power BI. And
I have a ton of
Excel experience.
I've got zero functional
Power BI experience. So
outside of, like,
clicking around the
Power BI system,
I know very little about it.
I didn't know if you
had any experience
either pushing data or tables
directly from an R Studio IDE
to cloud Power BI or
maybe using Connect
to facilitate that transfer.
I'm still very much
in exploratory mode.
But I didn't know if you
had any suggestions there.
- I'm going to have to defer
to the rest of the folks.
My experience with Power BI
and Tableau, those two platforms,
is virtually nill.
My hypothesis
is that if you're using
Power BI or Tableau, you can
source data probably from
a relational database or, like,
a CSV file. And I would
probably have a workflow where
I'm routinely populating data
that I could then visualize.
I may be off base there.
But if someone said, hey, you
got to use Power BI tomorrow, that's
an approach that I would
assume that I could take.
- It can't go without saying
to check out the Connect,
Posit Connect, docs that
Conor shared there, too.
And, Javier,
it looks like you have a
meeting with the team tomorrow,
so perfect timing to
chat about that too. Cool.
OK, another anonymous
question on Slido was,
"Do you see R markdown
or Quarto's publishing
functionality used in actuary
stats work, for example,
publishing your notebooks into
tables, docs, or
slides directly?"
- Not as often as I would like.
I am a big, big
fan of R Markdown slash Quarto.
I'm a little bit late
to the party in Quarto.
i use it.
The differences between
Quarto and R Markdown,
I'm still learning. So
I kind of use the terms
interchangeably.
I wrote a 600-page
textbook using R Markdown.
I do pretty much all of
my work in R markdown.
I find that I'm
writing notes. And
long-form comments suddenly become
the most important bit
in the document. And so it
just becomes easy to have R Markdown
and slash Quarto as my
starting point for work.
Professionally,
I've used it a lot.
Stakeholders very
often will want--
this isn't all that they
want-- but very often,
they can be satisfied with
a reasonably concise and
informative Word
document or PDF,
if you'd rather. But giving
them a Word document, like, OK,
here you go, here are
the tables, and here are the
graphs, and here's
the executive summary,
I think that's a great
way to share information.
Actuaries are not
using it as much.
I think there's not
as much awareness
of R Markdown.
I think the initial presumption
is that R's greatest strength,
or only strength, rather,
is in calculation.
It can absolutely do that.
It's got an incredible library of
statistical and
machine learning functionality.
But it does a lot
more than that.
That is slowly changing,
as with adoption
of R generally.
I see that as being a real
big selling point. When people
find out that they can replace
a very typical actuarial
and analytic workflow where I create
a plot in Excel and I
have to copy and paste it into
Word. That's operationally
inefficient. It's
operationally dangerous.
So
the notion that my entire
analytics report is in one file,
all of the code, all of
the narrative, all of the tables,
it's like telling me that I
can breathe underwater and fly.
It's really fantastic.
So I think that as actuaries
become aware of that
capability, they will get
pretty happy about it,
as will the people who
need to communicate with actuaries.
- I like the way you put that,
copying and pasting
is operationally dangerous.
- Yeah.
Yep.
I'm not the only actuary
who has been burned by that.
Where you're in a meeting,
you have everyone's looking
at the same file. And
the plot didn't update.
What do you mean we're losing
$1 billion a day? Oh, sorry,
that's yesterday's
graph. We're actually--
- It's really cool that your
book was built R Markdown as well.
I was wondering, what was that
process like of writing a book?
And how did you decide that
you were ready to write a book?
- Two things. One,
I'll start off by saying that
if it were not R Markdown,
there's no way I ever
would've written that thing.
I can't imagine-- certainly,
I'm not going to write
the entire document in lawtech.
There are people who
can, and God bless them.
I'm not the sort of
person that could have
that much lawtech [LAUGHS]
to think about.
Nor do I want to juggle about
12 or 13 different Word
documents or one monolithic
Word document. So R Markdown
was a tremendous solution. And
it was really empowering.
The
idea for the book
came about from
workshops that I and others
had been doing for the CAS.
We had 1-day workshops,
day and a half workshops.
And I found that there was
a lot of foundational material, thinking about
vectors, and slicing vectors,
and concatenation, and list,
and data frames. This was taking
up a large amount of scarce time.
Teach somebody to be an actuary
using R in about 7 and 1/2
hours. That's a tall order.
And when you spend about 3
hours or more just making sure
that folks understand
what a data frame is,
that scares time
that we're losing.
So those early slide decks,
probably all of which were
written in Markdown, by the
way, then translating to Reveal
JS or something like that,
we already had all of the
script for it for those. And I
sat down with those
decks and said, OK,
these look like book chapters.
So you take at
45-minute session.
And you've already got a lot
of the code in the examples.
And then, at the
time, I thought,
I'll just flesh this out with
a few paragraphs and, bang,
I'll have a book. It wound
up being more complicated than that.
It turns out that
it does take a little bit of
time to write all of the words
in such a way that
they make sense.
But at that point,
it was too late.
I was already I think
80 pages into it and
just needed to finish.
So that's kind of a story
about how that got started.
We started with some R Markdown
files.
The need for it is to give
folks some foundational
knowledge. And it just
kind of grew from there.
- Awesome. Thank you.
One other anonymous
question that came in--
and thank you to the team
gathering those for me in the
background-- was, "How do you
share your work currently,
especially when teams don't have R
and need to upload CSV files?"
- I don't have a real
strong need to do that.
So my sharing use case is
probably not going to resemble yours.
Because I'm guessing that the question
comes from some points of friction.
What I've done
is I'm going to
say SharePoints.
Grad school project,
I'm near the end
of a master's degree.
And so I had had some
grad school projects.
It's Google Drive.
The kids, they love Google.
Whereas the older corporate
people like SharePoint.
They're both fine.
That's what I use to share
data, like CSV. Files.
What I love to do
is to collaborate on GitHub.
Because it is controlled.
It feels safe
and deliberate.
There are obviously
some frictional points
there as well. But
beyond that, I'm curious
what other folks use,
if there is some interesting
magic bullet out there.
- Yeah. Any thoughts,
feel free to just
unmute-- I can watch--
or raise your hand here.
I know one way that came
up previously in a Hangout was
creating a shiny
application where
people who didn't
use R could upload
the data set and work
with it in the app.
But, yeah, any other ideas, feel
free to share in the chat too.
Another question,
I actually meant to ask
you this in the beginning.
But thinking about the projects
that you've been working on
lately and thinking into maybe the
next year ahead for your team,
what's something that
you're really excited about?
- Me, or others.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
You. You, yeah.
- Oh, gosh, what am
I excited-- oh, my.
I'm caught off guard by that.
My immediate response is
kind of disheartening.
I don't know that I'm
excited about anything.
I'll say this.
I'm excited about my next
trip to a new country
to talk about R.
I'm cheating a little bit here.
I went to South America for
the first time last year. I was
invited to give a
1-day workshop on
statistical learning in Bogota,
Colombia. That was fantastic,
similar to the experience that
I had going to Germany and
seeing a fresh perspective
on the work that I was doing.
Ditto down there.
The folks there were just
super motivated. And they had
a really interesting way of
looking at things. And I enjoyed
having the opportunity to
interact with other folks.
It's been a little while
now, but I taught --
I co-instructed a short
course on R in Rwanda.
That was fun.
So
nothing like that on the radar.
So I can't really claim
to be excited about that.
But if anybody's outside
of the United States,
particularly South
America or Africa,
and you want me to--
I'll pay my own airfare.
But if you'll give me an audience
for a couple of days or a week,
I'd love to go teach R to
anybody that wants to be taught by me,
-
What's the best place for
people to follow up with you on
that? Is it LinkedIn?
- That's a good place, yeah.
And feel free to
email me directly.
I'm going to give you my
workplace email in the chat.
So there's my
professional place.
And then you can also find me--
because I've got an R
crowd here, I've got my
consulting slash personal
email address in there as well.
That's that really,
really awful R joke that I made
when I created a blog over 10
years ago, that I'm just kind
of sticking with for now.
- Awesome. Thank you.
Another anonymous question
I saw that came in is,
"Is there much of an
actuarial R community, for example, folks
collaborating on common
packages with developers
between firms or sharing use
cases and best practices?
- So
I think there is
not yet a community,
though we're actively
working to create one.
There is a clique.
There is a small
group of people.
Every 2 weeks, there's
a meetup of some folks,
a virtual meetup,
of actuaries, who are using
open source, generally. We got
some Python folks
on there as well.
So there's a clique,
but not yet a community.
-
How would we find out about
this clique if we were interested?
- Good question. I hate
to sound kind of gatekeepy,
but I think you might
have to be an actuary.
- Oh, yes, I mean,
if somebody is an actuary
that wants to join.
- Send me an email.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: OK.
- Send me an e-mail.
And send me an email and
have a bit of patience.
I get a lot of email.
And my response rate is not
what I would like it to be.
Trust me, I really want to
respond, but I get a lot of
email. But please, please, please,
reach out to me, or
find me on LinkedIn as well.
Having a space for
actuaries and non-actuaries
to connect, that's actually
a really good thing,
that that's a good idea.
And I'd love to work with
any non actuaries to make that happen,
if anybody wants to
hit me up about that.
I'm glancing at Adam and
my gallery [INAUDIBLE].
- [CHUCKLES]
Sounds like Javier has a--
JAVIER: It's talk.
[LAUGHTER]
-
I was going to say sounds
like having your has a lot of
experience working
with actuaries as well.
- Yeah, great, great, yeah,
good to meet you both.
- OK,
Bill had a question in the
chat. And I'm going to read it,
bill, because I don't think
you are unmuting here. But
the question iet--
let me summarize a little bit--
do you have any opinion
on using ChatGPT
and the effects
on your industry?
- Not yet.
The only thing that I know--
I know very little about ChatGPT.
I want to be more conversant
in AI. A few years
back, I just kind of dabbled
with just some very,
very basic exercises ,
just to understand
the mechanical flow.
I'm blanking on the co-author,
but JJ Allaire has
a really good book
about AI that was kind
of my intro to that.
AI, generally, is--
how do I phrase this?
It's a slightly awkward
fit for actuarial practice.
And that's my view,
and it may be wrong.
There are definitely
cases where it works.
My sense is that AI relies
on a lot of observations.
Insurance claims,
thankfully, are pretty rare.
So those observations are
kind of hard to come by.
Now,
that's not to say that it has
no place whatsoever in the
actuarial workflow.
And we've got some papers
that have looked at this.
Last year, at a conference,
we had a really good
talk about long, short-term memory models
in loss reserving. So that's
an active conversation. And we're
looking at more and more
applications. Ron Richmond--
I'll throw his name
out there-- Is a very,
very talented actuary who's
looking at AI and deep learning
in actuarial applications.
We're turning to ChatGPT.
I've already outed
myself as an old man.
And I haven't really used
it very much, other than,
I think it was last
week or the week before,
I posted something on LinkedIn.
Someone had posed a
question to ChatGPT about
"The Grateful Dead."
I'm a big Deadhead.
And the answer was just wrong.
So
I know that some actuaries have
fed an actuarial exam to see if
it can pass. And so far,
it can't. So that's good news for
the profession, I suppose. But--
- Hey, Brian, that's
called hallucinating. As a Deadhead,
you should be familiar
with that concept.
- Well, OK.
I'm a Deadhead, but I'm
also a big database nerd.
And don't get me started
on the statistical analysis
of "Grateful Dead" performances.
But
at the moment,
especially, specifically something
like ChatGPT,
there are not active
applications that I'm aware of.
Deep learning generally, yeah
there are a few.
But
I see a lot more scope for
lift for actuaries out of Bayesian techniques.
Because
we simply don't have
a lot of observations.
But we have loads of qualitative
wisdom to bring to bear.
And I would say that
Bayesian techniques are
just woefully underutilized.
Actuaries were at the
forefront of promoting Bayesian
techniques for a long time.
There's a really good book
called, "The Theory
That Wouldn't Die."
Similar to "The Lady Tasting
Tea," it's kind of a popular,
easy-ish to read book
about statistics.
There is an entire
chapter about actuaries,
one of the few books you're
going to find that will do that.
But they're just
not mainstream.
And especially
with the advances
in something like MCMC,
there's no reason why
we can't be using them.
So I'm loads more bullish
on Bayesian techniques than I am
on deep learning, not immune
to deep learning. But that
is something that we're looking
at. But I see a lot
more lift out of Bayesian techniques.
- Just to confirm the book
that you mentioned by JJ Allaire,
is that the "Deep
Learning With R" book?
- Probably. He had
a co-author on that?
- Yep, worked with Francois
and Tomassz. Let me
put that into the
chat again here. Because I
actually just learned this week that
they updated this book.
So there's a second edition.
- Oh, great.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: We had
some new ones in the office.
And I asked JJ to sign one
the other day for the AstraZeneca conference.
- OK.
That's a really fantastic book.
I'll need to pick up
the second edition.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Awesome.
Let me just double
check here whether-- oh,
I see a few new questions here.
I was going to say,
if there's questions I have
missed in the last remaining 5
minutes or so here, feel free
to just raise your hand on Zoom.
But, Santiago, I see
one in the chat here.
SANTIAGO: It wasn't, like,
an actual question. But
on the conversation of GenAI
and foundational models--
I'm sure many others have
gotten this question.
We've been asked to look
for applications of these things
and how can we start
applying them internally?
I don't think they realize
applications are
fewer and far between.
But it depends. I don't know.
One of my proposals was,
as a consulting firm,
they're very big on brand.
I'm sure others have
to deal with that too,
what to capitalize,
what not to capitalize.
Why not train
something, like
Falcon or ChatGPT,
on your brand guide
so that you don't
have to read it.
You just pass it your
documents, and it would auto-brand
fix things for you.
It was kind of, like, a,
I don't know, a sarcastic
response. But I feel like
there would be application for that.
- Sarcastic or
not, it sounds like
a decent place for it.
I think there is a
lot of automatable
activity that ChatGPT
can help with.
- I love that example, Santiago.
I know we've talked
about this before here.
But I always think the best
way to make your proof of concept
or something that you share
with your leadership team stand
out is to actually use
your company brand in-- I don't
know, if it was a Shiny app,
using your logo and
the company colors.
Which I know Javier had
wrote in a blog post before,
would be cool to see if
he could run that through ChatGPT.
Let's see, any
other questions that I
may have missed here?
Let's see.
A question
I love to ask Brian is,
thinking about your career so
far and your mentors along the
way throughout your career,
is there a piece of career
advice that stands out to you?
- Good question.
I'm nor sure that I'm an
amazing person to give career
advice. I had a lot of
luck over the years. But
I've kind of
randomly gone from
one thing to the next.
And I don't know that
that's great advice.
Or maybe I could spin that
positively and just say
I feel like I benefited
from an openness
to do other things, and
also just an awareness that,
depending on what
industry you're in,
you will need some resilience.
I worked for a really cool,
really fun startup for
about a year, until
it just evaporated. Like,
you go into work one day and
they say, well, you know, it's been fun,
but the market has other
ideas about the viability of what
we're all doing here.
So you do need some
resiliency and some openness.
And I guess the mentor there
has just been experience,
just having lived through
some good fortune
and some not so good episodes, has been
what has taught me that.
I will say, though,
that I've got a really,
really cool network. I've
worked with some really,
really great people.
This is advice.
I'm not going to be the
first person to have shared this. But
as often as you can,
try to make sure that you're
the dumbest person at the table,
not so hard for me. But
being deliberate about that
has been useful.
- I appreciate that advice.
And
I also think,
listening to you today,
what I've learned is to also
ask for things that you want. Like,
if you want to go and travel to
a different country and teach a workshop there,
ask people [CHUCKLES] if--
If they're looking for that.
Brian, thank you so much
for joining us today and sharing
your experience.
This has been great.
I'm going to share your
LinkedIn here in the chat for
everybody as well.
But thank you all for
the great questions too.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.